rather than putting my cash in a bank
account I put them into treasuries
because either way while I wait to
decide what I want to do with the money
you can trade in and out of them very
quickly but the way that I do it is a
little bit unique and so rather than say
I'm just going to buy a bunch of T bills
today we buy tivo's that are due in six
months 12 months 18 months and 24 months
that way every six months I have
treasury bills with interest that come
due and then I take that money with the
interest and buy one 24 months out so
you end up creating a nice cash machine
that you actually get higher Returns on
the money over that period of time with
the same low risk that treasury bonds
afford you that always be cash bank
account anyone can do this